if you make the wrong decision if it's a
two-way door decision you walk out the
door you pick a door you walk out you
spend a little time there it turns out
to be the wrong decision you can come
back in and pick another door some
decisions are so consequential and so
important and so hard to reverse that
they really are one way door decisions
you go in that door you're not coming
back and those decisions have to be made
very deliberately very carefully um if
you can think of yet another way to
analyze the decision you should slow
down and do that so you know uh when I
CEO of Amazon I often found myself in
the position of being the chief slowdown
officer because somebody would be
bringing me a one-way door decision and
I would say okay I can think of three
more ways to analyze that so let's go do
that because we H we are not going to be
able to reverse this one easily maybe
you can reverse it it's going to be very
costly and very time consuming we really
have to get this one right from the
beginning and
uh what happens
unfortunately in companies what can
happen is that you have a oniz fits-all
decisionmaking process where you end up
using the heavyweight
process on all decisions including the
lightweight ones the two-way door
decisions two-way door decisions should
mostly be made by single individuals or
by very small teams deep in the
organization MH and oneway door
decisions are the ones that that are the
irreversible ones those are the ones
that should be elevated up to you know
the senior most Executives who should
slow them down and make sure that the
right thing is being done yeah I mean
part of the skill here is to to know the
difference between one way and two-way I
think you me yes yeah I mean I think you
mentioned Amazon
Prime the decision to sort of create
Amazon Prime as a one-way door and I
mean it's not it's unclear if it is or
not but it probably is and it's a really
big risk to go there there are a bunch
of decisions like that that are you
know changing the decision is going to
be very very complicated some of them
are technical decisions too because some
technical decisions are like quick
drying cement you know if you're going
to once you make them it gets really
hard I mean you know choosing which
propellants to use in a vehicle you know
selecting LNG for the booster stage and
selecting hydrogen for the upper
stage that has turned out to be a very
good decision but if you changed your
mind that would be a very that would be
a very big setback do you see what I'm
saying so that's the kind of decision
you scrutinize very very carefully other
things just aren't like that most
decisions are not that way most
decisions should be made by single
individ indviduals but they need and and
and done quickly in the full
understanding that you can always change
your mind yeah one of the things I
really liked perhaps this is not two-way
door decisions is uh I disagree and
commit phrase so don't so somebody
brings up an idea to you if it's a
two-way door you state that you don't
understand enough to agree but you still
back them I'd love to explain it yeah
disagree and commit is a really
important principle that saves a lot of
arguing yeah so you know I'm going to
use that in my personal life I disagree
but commit like it's very common in any
Endeavor in life in business and any you
know anybody where you have teammates
you have a teammate and the two of you
disagree yeah at some point you have to
make a decision and you know in
companies we tend to organize
hierarchically so there's this you know
whoever's the more senior person
ultimately gets to make the decision so
ultimately the CEO gets to make that
decision and the CEO may not always make
the decision that they agree with so
like you know I would I would often I
would be the one who would disagree and
commit some one of my direct reports
would very much want to do it do
something in a particular way I would
think it was a bad idea I would explain
my point of view they would say I Jeff I
think you're wrong and here's why and we
would go back and forth and I would
often say you know what I don't think
you're right um but I'm going to gamble
with you and um you're closer to the
ground truth than I am I've known you
for 20 years you have great
judgment I don't know that I'm right
either not really not for sure all these
decisions are complicated let's do it
your way but at least then you've made a
decision and and I'm agreeing to commit
to that decision so I'm not going to be
second guessing it I'm not going to be
sniping at it I'm not going to be saying
I told you so I'm going to try actively
to help make sure it works that's a
really important teammate Behavior
there's so many ways that dispute
resolution is a really interesting thing
in on teams and there are so many ways
when two people disagree about something
even the I'm assuming on the case where
everybody's well intentioned they just
have a very different op opinion about
what the right decision is and we have
in our society and inside companies we
have a bunch of um mechanisms that we
use to resolve these kinds of disputes a
lot of them are I think really bad so an
example of a really bad way of coming to
agreement is
compromise so compromise you know I
here's we're in a room here and I could
say Lex how tall do you think this
feeling is and you'd be like I don't
know Jeff maybe 12T tall and I would say
I I think it's 11t tall and then um we'd
say you know what let's just call it 11
and a half
feet that's compromised instead of the
right thing to do is you know to get a
tape measure or figure out some way of
actually measuring but think get in that
tape measure and figure out how to get
it to the top of the ceiling and all
these things that requires energy
compromise the advantage of compromise
as a resolution mechanism is that it's
low
energy um but it doesn't lead to truth
and so uh in things like the height of
the ceiling where truth is a knowable
thing you shouldn't allow compromise to
be used when you can know the truth MH
um another really bad resolution
mechanism that happens all the time is
just who's more
stubborn yeah this is also have let's
say two Executives who disagree and they
just have a war of attrition and
whichever one gets exhausted first
capitulates to the other one again you
haven't arrived at truth and this is
very
demoralizing so you know this is where
escalation I I try to ask people who you
know on my team and say never get to a
point where you are resolving something
by you know who gets exhausted
first escalate that I'll help you make
the decision like let's because that's
so de-energizing and such a terrible
lousy way to make a decision do you want
to get to the resolution as quickly as
possible because that ultimately leads
to high velocity of the yes and you want
to try to get as close to truth as
possible so you want like you know
exhausting the other person is not truth
seeking yes and compromise is not truth
seeking so you know it doesn't mean now
and there are a lot of cases where no
one knows the real truth and that's
where disagree commit can come in um but
it's it's um escalation is better than
War of Attrition escalate to you know to
your boss and say hey we can't agree on
this we like each other we're respectful
of each other but we strongly disagree
with each other we need you to you know
make a decision here so we can move
forward but decisiveness moving forward
quickly on on decisions as quickly as as
you responsibly can is how you increase
velocity most of what slows things down
is and is taking too long to make
decisions at all skill levels you know
so it has to be part of the
culture to get high velocity you know
Amazon has a million and a half people
and the company is still fast we're
still decisive we're still quick and
that's because the culture supports that
at every scale in a in a distributed way
try to maximize the velocity of
decisions
exactly
that